the war in Ukraine now in its second
year on Friday the Biden Administration
continued its support by you by sending
Ukraine a new two billion dollar package
of military aid and implementing new
sanctions on Moscow exactly one year
after Russia invaded the cost of the war
on Ukraine have been staggering
according to the United Nations about 19
000 Ukrainian civilians have been killed
or injured but officials acknowledge
that the real figure is likely much
higher more than 13 million ukrainians
have been displaced with more than 8
million fleeing the country as refugees
and the European Union's Justice
commissioner says 65 000 suspected war
crimes have been reported the conflict
has been costly to the Invaders as well
American and British military officials
estimate 200 000 Russian troops have
been killed or wounded and since the
start of the war the U.S has committed
32 billion dollars in military aid to
Ukraine Christina raffini is at the
White House with the latest on this new
round of military aid Christina good
morning
good morning Dana well at this time last
year predictions were bleak a lot of
governments including the U.S expected
Ukraine to fall in a matter of weeks or
months but ukrainians and their now
world's famous president held their
ground even pushing the Russians back
off some of it now the focus has shifted
to how to try to bring this conflict to
an end
on the one-year anniversary of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
President Biden defended the more than
32 billion dollars the U.S has committed
to help Ukraine defend itself
the cost of doing of walking away could
be considerably higher than the cost of
helping Ukraine maintain its
independence the President also told ABC
News the way to end the conflict is to
help Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski negotiate from a position of
strength he needs tanks he needs
artillery he needs air defense this week
the Pentagon announced a new two billion
dollar assistance package which will
include ammunition and small high-tech
drones but it will not include the
fighter jets ukrainians have been asking
for to defend against Relentless Russian
air assaults on their cities
there is no basis upon which there is a
rationale according to our military now
to provide f-16s but you're not ruling
it out I am ruling it out for now they
are however getting tanks Friday Poland
delivered the first batch of german-made
leopards and said more are on the way
but the longer the conflict continues
the harder it will be to keep NATO and
European allies all on the same page one
man
Vladimir Putin started this war
one man can end it Secretary of State
Anthony blinken told the United Nations
security Council Russia holds the key to
resolution if Russia stops fighting and
leaves Ukraine the war ends
if Ukraine stops fighting Ukraine ends
the latest concern China this week
Russian President Vladimir Putin
announced Chinese president Xi Jinping
will be coming to Moscow possibly in the
next few months German media is
reporting the Russians are negotiating
with the Chinese to manufacture drones
to be used on the battlefield CIA
director Bill Burns was asked about
Chinese support for Russia in an
interview for Face the Nation we're
confident that the Chinese leadership is
considering the provision of lethal
equipment we also don't see that a final
decision has been made yet and we don't
see evidence of actual shipments of
lethal equipment
now the Chinese are also among those
pushing for peace Beijing put forward a
12-point peace plan and although it
doesn't explicitly call for withdrawal
from Russia and President Biden
dismissed it president zielinski has
called for a summit with Xi Jinping Jeff
Christina rosini thank you very much